on parle de plafond de verre dans les
grandes entreprises mais dans la
création d'entreprise le plafond de
verre il est beaucoup dans la tête
être crédit par rapport à soi est ce que
je vais y arriver ce que j'ai les
compétences est ce que est ce que est ce
que est ce que c'est être crédible par
rapport à sa famille être crédible par
rapport à son environnement être crédit
par rapport à son banquier alors pour la
petite histoire il ya une étude qui est
sorti un an et demi qui dit que le
principal frein à l'entrepreneuriat des
femmes c'est leur conjoint de la femme
et la son équilibre son conjoint fait
partie de son équipe
elle a pas forcément envie de rompre son
mariage parce que son mari lui dit à un
moment donné où son conjoint lui dit non
je crois pas en une entreprise ça vaut
pas le coup
donc elle salah fera réfléchir donc elle
posera plus le pour et le contre par
rapport à ce que lui dit son conjoint et
elle en prendra le prendra plus en vente
donc ce qui fait qu'une entreprise qui
est trop à risque et ou conjoint n'y
crois pas du tout elle n'ira pas on a
une cinquantaine de personnes qui sont
venues sur la cinquantaine de personnes
on a retenu aujourd'hui 13
non pas que les autres on les a éliminés
mais souvent ce sont éliminés de même
c'est à dire que quand on a dit par
exemple ben nous on accompagne des
projets ambitieux il y en a qui partent
en disant c'est pas pour moi messieurs
ça va être un gros mot bonne dame donc
d'être dans un environnement avec
d'autres femmes qui ont passé le pas qui
ont créé leur entreprise
ça permet de se rassurer ça permet de
répondre à ces questions et d'avancer
mon premier travail jeu démarré dans une
entreprise de 1000 personnes sur mille
personnes y avait 100 cadres sur son
cadre on était cinq femmes dont trois de
moins de 25 ans et que peut-être mon
expérience justement qui a fait que j'ai
pu réussir dans un monde d'hommes mais
j'ai aussi envie de le transmettre
qu'il soit utile à d'autres qui se
posent les questions autrement et qui se
mettent des barrières l'ol devrait pas
s'en remettre
plus on va favoriser l'entreprenariat
féminin
plus on va avoir deux femmes qui vont
créer qui vont oser créer des
entreprises dans des milieux
qui sont justement la tech et le
numérique
[Musique]